I'll see Gomez my spear welcome to next
car game I'm playing the free demo
actually pre-order the game so I have
the alphabet the devil has this tech
demo the demo came with a tech demo no
[ __ ] and it's really funny and it's
really awesome if you haven't heard
about this game before
you're a bad to have your mind dude I
don't know what I'm supposed to try out
first it's a lot of stuff going on here
oh [ __ ] umm oh god I'm really bad at
this
good job so what's cool about this game
is that your car can break into
al-shabab get there eventually the car
can break into literally millions of
pieces and it's really uh Jesus what is
happening oh well that went great
I feel like I car needs a name Quasimodo
ha ha ha ha that ass is sassier than
Nicky Manette okay let's try the loop if
I can steer come on oh we're never gonna
make it oh ha ha ha well [ __ ] Oh God
poor car how is it still out and still
working yeah this is still better than
my girlfriend's car ok I can't go
backwards
let's just keep going backwards I'm not
ready to give up Quasimodo yet it's I
don't know how they did this but it's so
awesome alright let's go in these ready
go whoa that was amazing
I have a hat now I'll get you a hat
anyway
well best graphics ever all right see if
we can make it in without dying that's
what he said haha oh we're actually
better now man the controls are really
tight tighter than a Tigers put oh damn
I'm fine
is it still working so depressing go
yeah let's see how much damage we can do
to it I mean it I owe it's not a cannon
oh my hey I love cannons oh sorry I
really love cannons oh that was awesome
oh yeah you can't stop what's fat man
that ass is so sagging there's something
extremely satisfying about ruining and
reckoning [ __ ] what is this a stapler oh
my god I love staplers still working yes
don't with it you wait what what is this
oh oh oh I want to try that stop
stopping a bit question mode oh god but
- ah chair left shut up you're ugly
you're not capable of love everyone
knows that that's what they teach you in
the baggage Kevin oh God okay break
break break all right yeah careful
careful
careful camper Gephart Ewing sorry can't
do it
alright here we go let's see how far we
can fly breasts yeah I think that was a
little less I think that was hundred
twenty it's pretty good
how do you feel quasi shut up quasi no
one told you to speak oh it's a like
game I love that game I don't know
oh [ __ ] oh okay okay oh yeah I came in
like a car I guess
oh it's a good it's a Kawai Oh front
flip wait you won't stop being a
wrecking ball stop it Miley [ __ ] what
else do we need to check out okay that
looks fun let's do that
ran even going that fast oh yeah damn
you bluish animal itches oh can we jump
through the hole
I don't think so hey let's try it out
that's it tiniest hole ever are you
supposed to go through there challenge
accepted
are you serious okay
it is paused okay why well my size skill
it's not good enough I guess
come on
yeah yeah uh I don't know why but every
time everyone drives something in real
life they're really scared like I'm such
a good driver nothing bad ever happens
Oh God brake brake brake brake wait wait
see tied like a Tigers push it stop it
here we go here we go here we go [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't [ __ ] up now we did all that
year Oh Oh aah God we're fine
yep this lost a tire and like a lot of
important parts probably oh it looked
fine and then you see this [ __ ] shut up
crazy you know what just cuz you spoke
out goddamn it don't matter at all stop
it don't roll that I tell you a roll now
you go into cannon now patch play shut
up okay you go into cannon oh no you got
stuck
Wow do-over fight we're totally fine
look at this four five they were so
fight
yeah no problem
okay maybe a little slight problem let's
go through the stapler saving time
look at all the parts J says alright if
it survives this I swear I will eat my
own car you can barely even make it up
it still works of course why wouldn't it
the best car ever o4l quasi Oh wonder
what happens now
you eat oh damn hot yeah what happened
this game is really cool I never seen
anything like this
oh god you're getting mauled pretty bad
yes still going baby you can never stop
quasi go cry see
let's ride to the sunset baby or in
circles looks like a wheelchair he's
like really old now
why is quasi going no one knows oh [ __ ]
quasi quasi Sun him question doesn't
care he's old
it'll screw his mission will live on
we salute you quazy Oh God classic squid
quasi quasi this is the best car ever
alright press gonna have to end it there
it's a pretty awesome game and it's free
to check out so I'll leave a link in
description if you want to maybe like
you've enjoyed watching as always that
really helps me out a lot and I
appreciate it a lot so thank you stay
awesome bros I'll see you in the next
episode love you
uh huh well that was higher than you mom